Presidential Medal of Freedom we leave
this recorded event now to take you live
to that medal of freedom ceremony at the
White House as the recipients are being
introduced the nation's highest civilian
award goes to 16 individuals this year
including Senator Ted Kennedy and former
Supreme Court Justice Sandra Day
O'Connor live coverage now from the East
Room on c-span
Joseph's medicine crow
Stuart milk accepting on behalf of his
uncle Harvey Bernard milk
Sandra Day O'Connor
Sidney Poitier
Cheeta Ravana
Mary Robinson
Janet Davison rally
Archbishop Emeritus Desmond in kilo 2 2
Muhammed Yunus
Stephen Hawking
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States and first lady
Michelle Obama
thank you please be seated there are
many honors and privileges the stowed on
the occupant of this house but few mean
as much to me is the chance to award
America's highest civilian medal
the recipients that are here today this
is a chance for me and for the United
States of America to say thank you to
some of the finest citizens of this
country and of all countries the men and
women we honor today have had very
different wives and pursued very
different careers they're pioneers in
science and medicine they're gifted
artists and indomitable athletes they
have made their mark in the courtroom in
the community and in Congress and what
unites them is a belief that most
forgive me to those of you who are not
Americans but what we consider to be
that most American of beliefs that our
lives are what we make of them that no
barriers of race gender or physical
infirmity can restrain the human spirit
and that the truest test of a person's
life is what we do for one another the
recipients of the Medal of Freedom did
not set out to win this or any other
award they did not set out in pursuit of
glory or fame or riches rather they set
out guided by passion committed to hard
work aided by persistence often with few
advantages but the gifts Grace and good
name God gave them so let them stand as
an example here in the United States and
around the world of what we can achieve
in our own lives let them stand as an
example of the difference we can make in
the lives of others but each of their
stories stand as an example of a life
well-lived one of the way
things Susie Coleman did before she
passed away was asked her sister Nancy
to make her a promise
Nancy promised her she would prevent
other families battling breast cancer
from hurting the way there's head what
began with $200 and a list of friends
has become a global race for the Cure a
campaign that has eased the pain and
saved the lives of millions around the
world in the months after her sister's
death Nancy lay awake at night thinking
about the promise she had made and
wondering whether one person could
really make a difference Nancy's life is
the answer while an intern at Miami's
Jackson Memorial dr. Pedro Jose Greer
came across a patient in a coma without
a known name or address the homeless man
found by firefighters suffering from
tuberculosis in the days that followed
the physician little havana knows as dr.
Joe searched for clues about the
patient's life in the squalor under
Miami's highways deciding that Miami's
homeless deserved better dr. Greer
founded Camila health concern a clinic
that now offers care to over 4,000 poor
and homeless patients it's a life that
might be distilled into a question dr.
Greer asks all of us if we don't fight
injustice who will professor Steven
Hawkins was a brilliant man and a
mediocre student when he lost his
balance and tumbled down a flight of
stairs diagnosed with a rare disease and
told he had just a few years to live he
chose to live with new purpose and
happily in the four decades since he has
become one of the world's leading
scientists his work in theoretical
physics which I will not attempt to
explain further here
has advanced our understanding of the
universe his popular books have advanced
the cause of science itself from his
wheelchair he's led us on a journey to
the farthest and strangest reaches of
the cosmos in so doing he has stirred
our imagination and shown us the power
of the human spirit here on earth now
told he was too small to play college
football Jack Kemp became a pro
quarterback cut by four teams he led the
Buffalo Bills to two championships
football he once said gave him a good
sense of perspective about politics he'd
already been booed cheered cut sold and
traded makes me feel better a
conservative thinker a Republican leader
and a defender of civil rights he was
that rare patriot who put country over
party never forgetting what he learned
on the gridiron that it takes each of us
doing our part and all of us working
together to achieve a common goal
it's a life from which we can all draw
lessons Democrat and Republican alike
after purchasing an eight dollar racket
with money earned from chores eleven
year-old Billy gene declared a goal to
be the number one tennis player in the
world yet what we honor are not simply
her 12 Grand Slam titles 101 doubles
titles and 67 singles titles pretty good
Billie Jean
we honor what she calls all of the off
the court stuff what she did to broaden
the reach of the game to change how
women athletes and women everywhere view
themselves and to give everyone
regardless of gender or sexual
orientation including my two daughters a
chance to compete both on the court and
in life as Billie Jean once said we
should never ever underestimate the
human spirit nor should we underestimate
Billie Jean Kings spirit born and raised
in Jim Crow Alabama preaching in his
blood the reverend joseph Lowery is a
giant of the Moses generation of civil
rights leaders it was just king lowry
and a few others huddled in montgomery
who laid the groundwork for the bus
boycott and the movement that was to
follow a founder of the Southern
Christian Leadership Conference Lowery
was later asked to serve as president he
agreed to serve for one year but wound
up serving as he puts it for 21 year
terms
throughout his life some have called him
crazy but one of my favorite sermons
that I heard dr. Lowery once delivered
he said there's good crazy and there's
bad crazy and sometimes you need a
little bit of that good crazy to make
the world a better place
born just a generation past the Battle
of the Little Bighorn a grandson of a
scout for General Custer himself dr.
Joseph medicine crow was the first
member of his tribe to attend college
and earn a master's before completing
his PhD he left to serve in World War
two wearing Warpaint beneath his uniform
and a sacred feather beneath his helmet
Joseph's medicine crow completed the
four battlefield deeds that made him the
last crow war chief historian educator
and Patriot a good man a Buju
yah in chrome dr. medicine crows life
reflects not only the warrior spirit of
the crow people but America's highest
ideals his name was Harvey Milk and he
was here to recruit us all of us to join
a movement and change a nation for much
of his early life he had silenced
himself in the prime of his life he was
silenced by the act of another but in
the brief time in which he spoke and ran
and led his voice stirred the
aspirations of millions of people he
would become after several attempts one
of the first openly gay Americans
elected to public office and his message
of hope hope unashamed hope unafraid
could not ever be silenced it was Harvey
who said it best you got to give him
hope when a young Sandra day graduated
from Stanford Law School near the top of
her class in two years instead of the
usual three she would all she was
offered just one job in the private
sector
her prospective employer asked her how
well she typed and told her there might
be work for her as a legal secretary now
I cannot know how she would have fared
as a legal secretary but she made a
mighty fine Justice of the United States
Supreme Court Judge a judge and Arizona
Legislature cancer survivor child of the
Texas Plains
Sandra Day O'Connor is like the pilgrim
and the poem she some time quotes who
has forged a new trail and built a
bridge behind her for all young women to
follow it's been said that Sidney
Poitier does not make movies he makes
milestones milestones of artistic
excellence milestones of America's
progress on screen and behind the camera
in films such as the Defiant ones guess
who's coming to dinner
uptown Saturday night lilies of the
field for which he became the first
african-american to win an Academy Award
for Best Actor Poitier not only
entertained but enlightened shifting
attitudes broadening hearts revealing
the power of the silver screen to bring
us closer together the child of a
Bahamian tomato farmers Poitier once
called his driving purpose to make
himself a better person he did and he
made us all a little bit better along
the way Dolores Conchita Figueroa down
the Vandal knows the adversity that
comes with a difficult name I can relate
no into the world by the name that has
lit up Broadway marquees cheater
Rivera's career had an improbable start
accompanying a nervous classmate on an
audition she decided to audition herself
and impressed the choreographer Jerome
Robbins who would make her famous as
Anita in West Side Story
sassy electric that rare performer who
can sing dance and act
Chita Rivera revealed that still rare
ability to overcome when she recovered
from a car accident that shattered her
leg she ended up retaking the stage won
a Tony for kiss of the Spider Woman and
like her unforgettable Anita Chita
Rivera has shown that life can indeed be
bright in America the only girl in a
family of four brothers Mary Robinson
learned early on what it takes to make
sure all voices are heard as a crusader
for women and those without a voice in
Ireland Mary Robinson was the first
woman elected president of Ireland
before being appointed UN High
Commissioner for Human Rights when she
traveled abroad as president she would
place a light in her window that would
draw people of Irish descent to pass by
below today as an advocate for the
hungry and the hunted The Forgotten and
the ignored Mary Robinson has not only
shone a light on human suffering but
illuminated a better future for our
world after graduating from the
University of Chicago School of Medicine
in 1948 Janet Rowley got married and
gave birth to four sons making medicine
a hobby and making family her priority
it was not until she was almost 40 that
she took a serious medical research and
not until almost a decade later that she
discovered hunched over her dining room
table examining small photos of
chromosomes that leukemia cells are
notable for changes in their genetics a
discovery that showed cancer is genetic
and transformed how we fight the disease
all of us have been touched in some way
by cancer including my family and so we
can all be thankful that what began as a
hobby
became a life's work for Janet the glint
in the eye and the looked in the voice
are familiar to us all but the signature
quality of Archbishop Desmond Tutu says
Nelson Mandela his readiness to take
unpopular stands without fear perhaps
that explains what led the arch as he's
known to preach amid tear gas and police
dogs rallying of people against
apartheid and later when a free South
Africa needed a heart big enough to
forgive its sins Archbishop Desmond Tutu
was called to serve once more as
chairman of the Truth and Reconciliation
Commission Tribune of the downtrodden
voice of the oppressed Kantor of our
conscience Desmond Tutu possesses that
sense of generosity that spirit of unity
that essence of humanity that South
Africans know simply as boontem
thirty-five years ago a young economy
economic spre fessor at a university in
Bangladesh was struck by the disconnect
between the theories he was teaching in
class and the reality of the famine
outside so determined to help Mohammed
Yunus left the classroom for a village
and discovered that just $27 would free
dozens of artisans vendors and rickshaw
pullers from death offering himself as a
guarantor he withdrew a loan paid off
their debts and founded Grameen Bank a
bank that has dispersed over eight
billion dollars lifting millions of
people from poverty with micro loans
Muhammad Yunus was just trying to help a
village but he somehow managed to change
the world there's a story Ted Kennedy
sometimes tell us it's about a boy who
sees an old man tossing starfish
stranded by a receding tide back into
the sea there are so many asks the boy
what difference can your efforts
possibly make the old man studies the
starfish in his hand and tosses it to
safety saying it makes a difference to
that one
for nearly half a century Ted Kennedy
has been walking that beach making a
difference for that soldier fighting for
freedom that refugee looking for a way
home that seniors searching for dignity
that workers striving for opportunity
that student aspiring to college that
family reaching for the American Dream
the life of Senator Edward M Kennedy has
made a difference for us all these are
the 2009 recipients of the Medal of
Freedom at a moment when cynicism and
doubt too often prevail when our
obligations to one another are too often
forgotten when the road ahead can seem
too long or hard to tread these
extraordinary men and women these agents
of change remind us that excellence is
not beyond our abilities that hope lies
around the corner and that justice can
still be won in the Forgotten corners of
this world they remind us that we each
have it within our powers to fulfill
dreams to advance the dreams of others
and to remake the world for our children
and it is now my distinct and
extraordinary honor to ask each of them
to come forward to receive their award
as a military aide reads their citation
Sharleen strained from tragedy Nancy
Goodman Brinker has transformed the
nation's approach to breast cancer when
her sister was diagnosed in 1977 most
breast cancer victims knew relatively
little about the disease and suffered
from popular stigmas Nancy G Brinker
promised to challenge these norms she
founded susan g komen for the Cure in
honor of her sister and today the
organization supports research and
community awareness programs across the
United States and around the world
Nancy G bringers unique passion and
determination have been a blessing to
all those whose lives have been touched
by breast cancer
Pedro Jose Greer jr. dr. Pedro Jose Joe
Greer jr. has devoted his career to
improving medical services for the
uninsured a native of Miami he followed
his passion for helping others to
medical school and founded the cumulus
health concern CHC in 1984 as a medical
intern today CHC treats thousands of
homeless patients a year serving as a
model clinic for the poor and inspiring
physicians everywhere to work with
indigent populations
dr. Greer's tremendous contributions to
the South Florida community and our
nation as a whole stand as a shining
example of the difference one person can
make in the lives of many
Stephen Hawking persistent in his
pursuit of knowledge Stephen Hawking has
unlocked new pathways of discovery and
inspired people around the world he has
dedicated his life to exploring the
fundamental laws that govern the
universe and he has contributed to some
of the greatest scientific discoveries
of our time
his work has stirred the imagination of
experts and laypersons alike living with
a disability and possessing an uncommon
ease of spirit Stephen Hawking's
attitude and achievements inspire hope
intellectual curiosity and respect for
the tremendous power of science
jo-anne camp accepting on behalf of her
husband Jack French Kemp a statesman and
a sports icon Jack French Kemp advocated
for his beliefs with an unwavering
integrity and intellectual honesty on
the football field he earned the respect
and admiration of his teammates for his
judgment and leadership as a public
servant he plays country before party
and ideas before ideology Jack Kemp saw
bridges were other saw visions and his
legacy serves as a shining example for
all those who strive to challenge
conventional wisdom stay true to
themselves and better our nation
Cara Kennedy accepting on behalf of her
father Edward M Kennedy for more than
four decades
Senator Edward M Kennedy has boldly
fought for equal opportunity fairness
and justice for all Americans in his
tireless quest for a more perfect union
senator Kennedy has reformed our schools
strengthened our Civil Rights helped
seniors and working families lifted up
the poor and worked to ensure that every
American has access to quality and
affordable health care with volumes of
laws bearing his name and countless
lives touched by his extraordinary
passion senator Kennedy has accumulated
several lifetimes worth of achievements
the United States proudly recognized his
righteous citizen devout public servant
and giant among men
Billie Jean Moffitt King through her
example and advocacy Billie Jean Moffatt
King has advanced the struggle for
greater gender equality around the world
in an age of male-dominated sports her
pioneering journey took her from Long
Beach California to the lawns of All
England Club and the International
Tennis Hall of Fame her athletic acumen
is matched only by her unwavering
defense of equal rights with Billie Jean
King pushing us the road ahead will be
smoother for women the future will be
brighter for LGBT Americans and our
nation's commitment to equality will be
stronger for all
Reverend Joseph E Lowery Reverend Joseph
E Lowery has marched through life with
faith and purpose carrying with him the
legacy of a movement that touched
America's conscious and changed his
history at the forefront of the major
civil rights events of our time from the
Montgomery bus boycott to protest
against apartheid he has served as a
tireless beacon for non-violence and
social justice as a pastor and civil
rights advocate he co-founded the
Southern Christian Leadership Conference
and championed the cause of peace and
freedom around the world the United
States proudly honors this outstanding
leader
Joseph's medicine crow as a warrior and
living legend history flows through dr.
Joseph medicine crow hi bird born on a
reservation and raised by traditional
grandparents he became the first member
of his tribe to earn a master's degree
for his valiant service in World War two
he was awarded the status of crow war
chief and his renowned studies of the
first Americans and contributions to
cultural and historical preservation
have been critical to our understanding
of America's history Joe medicine crow
is a symbol of strength and survival and
the United States honors him for his
dedication to this country and to all
Native Americans
Stuart milk accepting on behalf of his
uncle Harvey Bernard milk
Harvey Bernard milk dedicated his life
to shattering boundaries and challenging
assumptions as one of the first openly
gay elected officials in this country
he changed the landscape of opportunity
for the nation's gay community
throughout his life he bought
discrimination with visionary courage
and conviction before his tragic death
in 1978 he wisely noted hope will never
be silent and called upon Americans to
stay true to the guiding principles of
equality and justice for all
Harvey Milk's voice will forever echo in
the hearts of all do to carry forward
his timeless message
Sandra Day O'Connor
Sandra Day O'Connor has paved the way
for millions of women to achieve their
dreams completing law school in just two
years he graduated third in her class at
a time when women rarely entered the
legal profession with grace and humor
tenacity and intelligence she rose to
become the first woman on the United
States Supreme Court her historic 25
term tenure on the court was defined by
her integrity and independence and she
has earned the nation's lasting
gratitude for her invaluable
contributions to history and the law
Sidney pottier
ambassador and actor Sidney pottier has
left an indelible mark on American
culture rising from the tomato farms of
the Bahamas his talent led him to
Broadway Hollywood and global acclaim in
front of black and white audiences
struggling to write the nation's moral
compass Sidney pottier brought us the
common tragedy of racism the inspiring
possibility of reconciliation and the
simple joys of everyday life ultimately
the man would mirror the character and
both would advance the nation's dialogue
on race and respect
Chita Rivera
from stage to screen Chita Rivera has
captured America's imagination with her
magnetic presence and radiant voice over
a career that has spanned a half-century
she has received numerous accolades for
her performances including two Tony
Awards six additional Tony nominations
and the Kennedy Center Honors award as
fearless as Anita in West Side Story and
as self-reliant as Aurora and kiss of
the Spider Woman she has broken barriers
under Broadway's lights and inspired a
generation of women to follow in her
remarkable footsteps the United States
honors Chita Rivera for her lifetime of
achievement as one of America's great
artists
Mary Robinson
for Mary Robinson the fight to end
discrimination and suffering is an
urgent moral imperative she has been a
trailblazing crusader for women's rights
in Ireland and a forceful advocate for
equality and human rights around the
world whether courageously visiting
conflict stricken regions are working to
inject concern for human rights into
business and economic development Mary
Robinson continues as important work
today urging citizens and nations to
make common cause for justice
Janet Davison Raleigh
dr. Janet Davison rally was the first
scientist to identify a chromosomal
translocation as the cause of leukemia
and other cancers considered among the
most important medical breakthroughs of
the past century after enrolling at the
University of Chicago at age 15 she went
on to challenge the conventional medical
wisdom about the cause of cancer in the
1970s which had placed little emphasis
on chromosomal abnormalities her work
has proven enormous ly influential to
researchers worldwide who have used her
discovery to identify genes that cause
fatal cancers and to develop targeted
therapies that have revolutionized
cancer care the United States honors
this distinguished scientist for
advancing genetic research and the
understanding of our most devastating
diseases
Archbishop Emeritus Desmond MP low to 2
with unflagging devotion to justice
indomitable optimism and an unmistakable
sense of humor Archbishop Emeritus
Desmond in Pula tutu has stirred the
world's conscious for decades as a man
of the cloth he has drawn the respect
and admiration of a diverse congregation
he helped lead South Africa through a
turning point in modern history and with
an unshakeable humility and firm
commitment to our common humanity he
helped heal wounds and lay the
foundation for a new nation Desmond Tutu
continues to give voice to the voiceless
and bring hope to those who thirst for
freedom
Muhammed Yunus
with his belief and the self-reliance of
all people professor Muhammad Yunus has
altered the face of Finance and
entrepreneurship as an academic he
struggled with pervading economic
theories and their effects on the people
of his native Bangladesh yearning for a
new way of lifting people out of poverty
he revolutionized banking to allow
low-income borrowers access to credit in
the process he has enabled citizens of
the world's poorest countries to create
profitable businesses support their
families and help build sustainable
communities in doing so Muhammad Yunus
has unleashed new avenues of creativity
and inspired millions worldwide to
imagine their own potential
before we break up
why don't we all give an extraordinary
round of applause
thank you very much for joining us
everyone thank you very much
it's recipes that's please be seated at
this time other guests are invited to
proceed or such
once again by the jacuzzi with reception
thank you